[Música]
a mí este señor me suena entiéndame no
es que no sepa quién es este señor es mi
padre exprimir langarica si les digo que
me suena es porque a pesar de las miles
de luces y de bombillas que vendió en su
tienda de lámparas de victoria para mí
más que un hombre de luz fue un hombre
sonoro
porque mi padre se pasó media vida
persiguiendo una melodía
[Música]
y
cada fin de semana durante más de 30
años mi padre salía a buscar palomas
nuestros padres salían a cazar oa por
setas el mío iba por palomas la se
encontraba revolviendo en tiendas de
discos en el rastro en madrid' en bayona
y una por una consiguió reunir más de
mil versiones de esta canción ya ven
años y años dedicados a una colección
que empezó en una discusión de una barra
de bar sobre cuál sería la canción más
versionada de la historia una discusión
que hoy en día resolveríamos en un
minuto con un smartphone consultando a
sanz google
de hecho internet tuvo mucho que ver en
las andanzas de mi padre como
coleccionista porque en los años 80 con
un módem descacharrado de esos que
sonaba como teléfono viejo se quedó
atónito al descubrir que en el mundo
había muchos más para lo mixtas como el
que recopilaban versiones de la canción
y que estudiaba en su historia así que
no no ya atónito se quedó estupefacto
cuando comprobó que un único musicólogo
alemán tenía más versiones de la paloma
que él
desde ese momento mi padre se dedicó a
demostrar que la paloma es nuestra que
es de aquí de álava de lanciego de
vitoria que nos pertenece refunfuñaba
cada vez que se la encontraba en una
antología de tangos argentinos con una
recopilación de canciones rusas cuando
un presentador la presentaba como la
canción cubana por excelencia
refunfuñaba hoy aquí por su memoria y
por su legado me gustaría traerles la
historia de la canción más cosmopolita y
viajera que puedan imaginar comenzamos
el primer palo mixta de la historia don
sebastián iradier y salaverry músico
vasco que en 1860 compone esta melodía
más que una gran sinfonía fue una
melodía hoy hablaríamos de un hit
internacional pero en pleno siglo 19 en
unos meses está sonando en todo el sur
de europa entre otras cosas porque señor
iradier y salaverry era profesor de
música de la emperatriz eugenia de
montijo de la emperatriz de francia
el éxito es arrollador y desde el inicio
comienzan a aparecer las primeras
versiones de las miles y miles que
vendrían después para que se hagan una
idea en 1865 cinco años después de ser
compuesta ya tenemos registradas palomas
en italiano y palomas en francés y así
anida la paloma en el sur de europa en
grecia en italia en francia y en españa
la paloma que nosotros conocemos la
paloma lírica y romántica para que se
haga una idea de esa dimensión
paneuropea meridional de la paloma
vamos a escuchar un pequeño extracto de
una versión grabada en griego en la
escala italiana de milán por la
profesora de canto de maria sophia calle
de los pueblos que quizá le suene más si
les digo que es maría callas y que para
siempre uniría nuestra paloma a su
grecia natal
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esos esos surcos de vinilo que andan por
ahí por el sonido bueno pero la paloma
no se conforma con el éxito del sur de
europa y decide emigrar para seguirla en
su primer viaje necesitamos un cuento un
cuento de príncipes y de princesas
el vídeo dura de new year el mal
[Música]
es un éxito
biutiful
al agua
esa meta
[Música]
adriano
no sé
hay que sacar
flores en soria
a méxico le dice reconocerán por lo
menos los que tengan peinen canas a una
jovencísima bette davis encarnando a
nuestra princesa de cuento a carlota de
bélgica paseando junto a su enamorado
maximiliano de habsburgo el archiduque
de austria se conocen en viena en un
baile con la canción de moda y deciden
que esa será para siempre su canción y
también hemos oído que le dice al final
nos vamos a méxico porque han sido
proclamados emperadores del incipiente
imperio mexicano y así es como nuestra
paloma cruza por primera vez el charco
va a méxico de la mano de los
emperadores y por supuesto triunfa otra
vez en las clases altas en los bailes de
palacio pero a veces la historia
convierte los cuentos en pesadillas y
cinco años después de haber arribado en
veracruz
maximiliano pedirá escuchar su canción
por última vez antes de ser asesinado
por las tropas juaristas revolucionarias
esta es la primera pero no la última
guerra que librará nuestra canción
mientras las tropas imperiales hacen de
la paloma su estandarte musical y la
tocan antes de entrar en batalla entre
las clases populares mexicanas comienzan
a aparecer letrillas que ridiculizan al
emperador usando su misma melodía y que
por supuesto ensalzan la figura de los
seres revolucionarios y así en méjico
aparece otra paloma distinta que la que
conocemos aquí que para ellos es una
paloma puramente mexicana es una paloma
contestataria y revolucionaria que desde
entonces y hasta nuestros días ellos
consideran una canción patriótica y que
habla de la lucha de clases decenas de
versiones como esta que escuchamos
[Música]
y más
estos estados son
de su sismo que no
de los seis son hombres
y
y acá no
puros puros chinacos que hacen de esta
su canción una canción que se escuchó en
chiapas ensalzando a 'subcomandante
marcos' o ahora mismo esta es de los
problemas que hay en las fronteras con
la gente que no les dejaban entrar el
gigante del norte
pero fíjense que si hay un país que ha
hecho suya la paloma es sin duda
alemania
en alemania donde la paloma ha echado
raíces quizás raíces no sería el mejor
término para definir lo que el pueblo
alemán siente por la paloma porque para
ellos siempre será esta canción que
apareció en sus puertos del norte en un
barco y con el sonido de un acordeón es
en alemania donde nuestra paloma ha
pasado mejor tiempo y ha echado más
raíces y han tenido más palomitas en la
actualidad podemos encontrar centenares
de versiones de la paloma desde óperas
dodecafónicas fundadas en la canción
cada movimiento habla de una parte del
palomo desde que nací pichón hasta que
muere hasta versiones de hard metal de
grupos impermeables y que van a permitir
no poner aquí créanme que existen vale
para que se hagan una idea de este
idilio entre el pueblo alemán y nuestra
paloma en mayo del 2004 el ayuntamiento
de hamburgo solicita su inclusión en el
libro guinness de los récords como el
coro más grande de la historia por haber
reunido a 88 mil 600 personas para
cantar al unísono una sola canción dieta
v la paloma
swart se quedan acá
en esto
[Música]
y alguien una paloma que para nosotros
está en el orbe a lo más alto hasta
donde ha llegado
y si la paloma ha acompañado al pueblo
alemán toda su vida a otro pueblo le
acompaño a la muerte está documentado
por cientos de supervivientes que la
paloma sonaba cuando las interminables
hileras de judíos se dirigían a las
cámaras de gas en auschwitz treblinka
pero porque los nazis alemanes iban a
utilizar su himno marinero para matar
gente para una marcha mortuoria no tiene
lógica la encontramos y vemos un mapa de
la época y si recordamos la historia de
amor todos los campos de exterminio
nazis no se encontraban en alemania
todos estaban en polonia y polonia
formaba parte del imperio austrohúngaro
de maximiliano y en austria en hungría y
en polonia la paloma era y es una marcha
fúnebre una marcha que trajeron esos
miles de soldados desde mexico que
venían heridos y derrotados y con la que
enterraban a sus muertos y además
despedían a su emperador asesinado
pero la paloma no solamente estuvo
presente en la guerra en los campos de
exterminio también los tuvo en los
campos de batalla se da la paradoja de
que la paloma en la segunda guerra
mundial en ambos frentes europeos sonaba
en francés en italiano sonaba en inglés
y sonaba en alemán pero a veces sonaba
en frentes opuestos y a la vez a ver si
la cantaba más alta durante las treguas
cosas de la paloma
en fin me gustaría ahora con ustedes
viajar al país que él ha hecho suya al
compás de una guitarra y no es el
nuestro a pesar del maravilloso arreglo
para evitar la clásica que hizo el
maestro francisco tárrega que le
introdujo en la música de cámara o el
más maravilloso arreglo del gran paco de
lucia que se la llevó al mundo flamenco
en el país del que les habló nuestra
paloma suena así
[Música]
aloha hawai caldas y la paloma pero
vamos viajamos a hawai
de la mano
un emperador que tuvieron allá con
nombre de pokemon se llama kamehameha
tercero
me dedico al google kamehameha tercero
tuvo la brillante ocurrencia de importar
decenas de miles de cabezas de ganado
que acabaron pastando a sus anchas por
las laderas de hawai porque ningún
hawaiano sabía cómo manejarlas sólo
sabían pescar vale para enmendar este
error kamehameha palito palito paliza
busquen en google escribe al gobierno
mexicano y le pide unos centenares de
experimentados vaqueros pues para pues
para al toro por los cuernos y que
se llevan en sus vaqueros en su viaje
sólo de ida a hawai se llevan sus
monturas se llevan sus guitarras y se
llevan su paloma una paloma que los
hawaianos enseguida adecúan a sus
cadenciosos ritmos locales tumban la
guitarra y la hacen la melodía más
famosa de su slide guitar esa guita para
que tenga todo han tumbado a veces
incluso con un cilindro deslizando la
sobre el mástil y así como una canción
absolutamente hawaiana una melodía que
no tiene letra que es anónima
inspira al pueblo de hawai la conocería
80 años después otro rey que el sitio
esas islas el rey del rock'n'roll
[Música]
no ha sido ésta la duración
no
viudo que en una que se destruye
hechos
todo menos el bañador es maravilloso en
esta
bueno pues así se la encuentra el bis
baja wa a rodar una de sus primeras
películas emblemáticas blue hawai la
primera de las tres que rodó en esas
islas y ahí encuentra esta melodía como
se anónima no tiene letra se tiene que
inventar el título la letra y la utiliza
para crear una de sus composiciones más
personales su famosísima no humor que
graba hasta en cuatro ocasiones
distintas a lo largo de su carrera
musical
otros artistas anglosajones de la talla
de chubby checker de chuck berry de
charlie parker o the artist out se han
encargado de subirla a las listas de
éxitos anglosajones en diversos momentos
al ritmo de jazz de swing o de ritmo
blues ya ven ustedes que hay palomas y
palomas que hay versiones que hay
versiones de versiones que hay palomas
famosísimas y palomas que nadie conoce
que la pueden escuchar si van a un
teatro de ópera o si pone una película
la banda sonora encuentra en la en un
anuncio de televisión o si van paseando
por la calle y hay un músico tocando un
acordeón
son palomas escritas en decenas de
idiomas que cuentan historias distintas
con títulos distintos y que depende en
qué sitio del mapa nos situamos en el
mundo tendrá significados incluso
contradictorios revolucionario o
romántico o atávicas o mortuorias si
tuviera más tiempo si no ves bien
haciendo ya señales les contaría porque
en cuba es una canción cubana porque en
rusia la tocan con un instrumento se
llama la honra y es la canción que con
el que hacen el examen del instrumento
una balalaika pero pero para cultos con
alguna cuerda más tiene o porque en la
isla de zanzíbar es una canción
sanz ibarreña de arriba a abajo y la
utilizan en las bodas
mi padre se pasó ya les digo toda la
vida reivindicando que la paloma era de
aquí que era nuestra que nos pertenecía
reivindicando su origen y reivindicando
su autoría pues yo estoy de acuerdo en
que la paloma nos pertenece pero no es
nuestra porque seamos vitorianos o
vascos o españoles oa la vez es la
hacemos nuestra cada vez que la antón
amos en nuestras comidas familiares en
la sobremesa al ritmo de manera y si
otros países si otra gente si otra
cultura quieren cantarla pues deberíamos
enorgullecer lo deberíamos alegrarnos y
deberíamos recordar que una paloma es un
animal viajero por definición
y que desde tiempos inmemoriales la
hemos utilizado para mandar los mensajes
de un sitio a otro y el mensaje que
ayudaría a la pata de esta paloma sería
la sencilla frase escrita en un
pentagrama que diría lo mismo que dijo
su autor hace más de 150 años sea tu
ventana llega una paloma tratada con
cariño que es mi persona gracias
[Aplausos]